oh my gosh sorry we're running late it's
because I sprayed my eyeball with
perfume I I heard have you ever done
that with like cologne
um
I can't say I have fortunately make me
feel better Marcus I know I have every
day honestly I just yeah no I uh I heard
about that I'm so glad you're back and
Rob and I were talking about dogs um do
you have dogs are you a pet lover I I'm
a pet fiend uh that made it sound a lot
more extreme than it is I know I like it
but I do have a dog that oh look at him
his name is uh Odin he's a big
sweetheart he's a Rottweiler uh yeah
he's uh three years old and yeah he's
the love of my life love that dude look
at those snuggles I know he's the
greatest I miss him he lives with my
parents I I got my own apartment
whatever you know 23. so really so
really your parents got a dog yeah they
have a dog now which is like it's a
rough situation I feel like a lot of I I
swore I would never be that kid I was
like I'm responsible I'm gonna take care
of this I did it we had another dog
named Zeus uh unfortunately passed away
recently but Zeus was a beagle
um and I begged my parents for years to
get a get a dog and when we finally got
one I was waking up in at 6am I was
feeding him I was going to all the
appointments I was doing everything yeah
I was making sure but with Odin I
slacked off in my older age I've gotten
that's because your young 20s and you're
just having fun exactly that's kind of
what you're supposed to do yeah so how's
your New Year going are you the guy that
like makes resolutions and like keeps
them no I have such a weak will
um yeah me too I um I made the
resolution to eat healthier that did not
stick I had in and out yesterday on the
way back from an event
um so it did not last long did not last
long at all in and out of worth it it's
worth it it is Animal Style three by
three animal style no pickles light
tomato animal fries extra well done nice
with grilled onions I
and I like diamonds
they're nice well congratulations
grownness just got picked up for another
season that's awesome season six here we
come yeah it's such a trip because
you've been a part of this whole thing
for so long like a decade right yeah
yeah I feel I always joke people I'm
like when you've seen as much as I've
seen the ripe age of 23. uh no but I've
been yeah we've been doing it since I
was 13 years old uh junior is a
fantastic character I wouldn't want to
be on this journey with anyone else it's
so rare though that you get that
character and get to like grow up in
that character and you are that's so
rare yeah it's crazy I think I mean I
credit all our writers and being able to
evolve the character over the years he
hasn't remained stagnant he's kind of
continued to grow and people have
watched him grow up in front of their
eyes
um and I think that's part of the
success of the show so absolutely I
agree well we were talking
um about your dog earlier or dogs
um is it and I'm sorry about Zeus that
sucks losing a pet
um is it true that you are an expert at
naming dog breeds like big just based on
the photo yeah yes I'm pretty good like
I I can name most dog breeds I'm
confident
um I really want to challenge this
knowledge oh boy exactly I should just
spoke up
you shouldn't tell us things because I
want you to play a game we play a game
with me I will okay okay if you said no
it still was gonna happen okay all right
let's do another quick commercial break
everybody be sure to watch grownish on
freeform the second half of the fifth
season debuts today
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]